it is day two of us bringing you eight
on your side reports on avoiding black
friday pitfalls now monday we gave you
tips on not falling for those low
quality and limited availability of the
doorbuster dales today we tackle those
rebate mail-ins and some misleading
sales
with so many stores promoting different
deals on different products on different
days and times finding the best sales
can be confusing and overwhelming
nationally recognized consumer savings
expert andrea warwick says don't fall
for the deals that require you to mail
in a rebate to get a lower advertised
price here's the catch they know a lot
of people forget to mail in the rebates
maybe they lose the receipt or don't
have all the items they need to
qualify for that rebate and then they
miss out on the savings she finds it's
better to go to a retailer who has the
same item and maybe you pay a little bit
more but you get the instant savings
without the hassle
you can also get money back on your
purchase by using coupon apps like
coupon cabin and slide and speaking of
coupons warwick says stores want you to
think that everything is going to be on
sale on black friday but the reality is
it's usually limited to certain products
she says they're not the biggest
discounts you can find all season long
either so apply a coupon code and don't
assume the sale price is the lowest
price you can get sometimes you have to
apply a coupon code to get a deeper
discount so just go to a site like
couponfollow.com where you can search by
store name to pull coupons quickly and
you can even download a coupon plugin
like scently that adds those deals
automatically
and we will continue our stories for you
tomorrow as well
how to avoid those black friday pitfalls